you know whether it was the documentary
The Memoir or Pamela's Garden Eden you
have been documenting your life since
you were a kid whether it was journals
videos all your keepsakes tough question
if you had to keep one thing out of all
of your archives what would it be oh
some of my kids little baby clothes
maybe I know I'm ridiculous but we
didn't even show that but I have like in
my in my Loft and in my storage place I
have like all the kids artwork all the
kids report cards there's stories that
they've written and their little baby
clothes some of these little things and
lots of pictures and memories of them as
they were growing growing up
um and then I go to the other side of my
storage unit and I have like every VHS
copy of VIP like what was I saying that
before I love that show and stuff thanks
but I have created some stuff like that
so I don't know I mean my journals I had
like in a little safe and I'm always
writing so I had all those yellow legal
pads and tons of journals and and I
probably I don't have all my journals
but I have a lot of them and so when
Brandon said to me
let's you need to tell your story mom
you need to tell everybody like we need
to he really wanted people to see his
mom who she really is and I said well I
don't know if I've really kept anything
and then we opened it all up and I kept
everything so I just said the only thing
I want to know about this documentary is
nothing don't tell me anything I don't
want to see it I don't want to I just
want everything out there I mean I know
there's no dead bodies up there so
anything other than that can't be too
bad yeah I said just go for it I love
that could you have trusted anybody else
other than Brandon to tell your story
well I mean it's not just Brandon it's
Ryan White is a great director and he
you know directed the film and he went
through all the archives and he has a
team of people that went through that so
I I mean it's not even curated really by
Brandon Brandon was just kind of the
go-between yeah and he obviously made
the whole thing happen but he also
understood that it wasn't something that
we wanted to manipulate in any way we
just wanted it to be 100 100 you know
disclosure and
and let you know people kind of decide
decide for themselves what they think
instead of trying to manipulate
something I had no idea you were first
discovered at a BC Lions game like that
seems like such a moment of Fate you're
just in the audience then you're up on
the big like Jumbotron if you had not
gone to that game how do you think your
life would have turned out I mean I
don't think I don't look at I don't I
guess I don't think that way yeah it
happened and so here I am so I don't
know I mean again I when I was a kid I
wanted to be an archaeologist I wanted
to be a nun I wanted to be a librarian
these are the things I wanted to be I
don't know how I took the another turn
but I was a big I loved being at the
library I was always there as a kid my
mom just dropped me off there and picked
me up later like it was just somewhere
that I love to be so it's funny that I
actually got to write a book yeah
so that's exciting not every not
everybody hits icon status you've
definitely hit icon status I mean people
dress up for you as Halloween they love
you so much that must mean you've made
it right did you have your own Halloween
costume you have made it uh is that wild
do you like that it's weird
it's weird because I feel like I've been
observing my life as an outsider because
it's just yeah one Halloween costume
after another but I think what's great
about the documentary and the and the
book I hope is that I feel more like a
person now and not like a cartoon
character yeah so it's nice so I do I'm
honored and flattered when people dress
up as me as Halloween or you know I see
like Tommy and Pam or Kid Rock and Pam
or like you know the the barbed wire or
Baywatch yeah I'm a bunch of Halloween
costumes but there is a person
underneath all of it and and I've had a
lot of fun I mean I don't
it's I never felt like a victim or and I
don't I'm not complaining about anything
I'd always feel grateful for every
opportunity that I had but I always just
tried to make the most fun I wanted to
have the most fun with it yeah with
everything uh have you paid attention to
any of the celebrities who've dressed up
as you do you have a favorite no no no
no no no no no no no but I you know I
don't I don't know not that I don't
appreciate it but I just I don't know I
think it's funny and I said I don't
watch I don't look online I don't look
at things I don't have any apps on my
phone yeah I I don't obsess in that
because it takes so much of your time I
mean if people are on Instagram all the
time those are three hours you're
killing a day and you could be doing
something else you could be reading it
like you know Vivian Westwood was a
great friend of mine and she always said
if you're weak you'll never be boring
but like reading a book not just
scrolling and doing all this kind of
stuff I just feel like these um kind of
lack of intimacy and
and that's why I'm actually starting a
little newsletter I'm writing these
journaling and stuff that's funny my
kid's like your mom you're going to keep
on writing let's just do this open
Journal you know where you can actually
keep writing weekly and people can see
it because I'm really excited about the
response I'm getting I was so scared to
put out the book and so scared before
the documentary came out thinking either
people are just going to be
they won't care or oh no they care maybe
they'll be annoyed by it or who cares it
just seems so self-serving sometimes but
um I'm so grateful that I got to tell my
story and I'm so grateful that people
are
embracing it and people on the street or
people in the airport and and just
meeting people and signing books for
them and hearing their stories has been
really nice and Britney Spears recently
came out to support you to show support
for your sons uh what's it like not only
getting support from your fans but other
celebrities like Britney Spears well I
wrote her a letter back and hopefully
she's received it by now but um just a
private letter I feel like
you know it's it's hard when the people
closest to you
betray you or use you and you know
there's there's you're like a money
maker you're like um it's painful when
when you think about your you know
handful of friends or your family and
but I'm so fortunate in my life because
I mean I didn't have kids so they would
you know get older and then
um fight for me I just you didn't even
know that so you're fighting for them
and you're protecting them you never
want to put that on your kids that I
didn't want to make it their job but
Brandon and Dylan are both very
protective and they're both really good
at business and so they just kind of
took it on as like a family Legacy
project this is just a it's an
experiment we're thinking we're playing
with it we don't have a huge team behind
us it's just us so it's cute because
Dylan's back home he's posting a
newsletter today and it's cute because
we don't have this big team behind us
this is really authentic it's just us
and we'll probably make lots of mistakes
but I kind of like it better that way
yeah no the whole thing feels very real
I think that's why it's connecting with
so many people whether it's your show
the the doc the Memoir like I know
that's how I'm instantly feeling
everybody here we've all talked about it
my producers like we're like oh did you
read this like it's really really really
good
another thing that I know is so
important to you you've always been so
passionate about animals people who are
vulnerable the environment you know of
all the work that you've done with the
Pamela Anderson Foundation what is the
one thing that you're most proud of
well with Peta it was like I was
laughing with Dan Matthews the other day
who was the vice president of PETA
um at that time I was pregnant with
Brandon when I did my first campaign I'd
rather go naked than my fur
or give her the cold shoulder yeah so
that one that was I was pregnant with
Brandon there so and now it was funny to
be in New York in the same place 26
years later and we've done so much work
together I mean we've created Animal
Welfare laws whether we're none we've
had whales released from whale prisons
in Russia and you know stopped designers
wearing using fur I think there's just
it's endless you know really kind of
encourage veganism where I think I was a
little bit ahead of my time back then
talking about sustainability and
veganism because now it's so in
fashioned so it's it's um you know
Pete's done great work and a lot of
animal groups that I work with I'm
always working with animal groups and
and I'm and just always trying to find
ways to use the attention for a good you
know and kind of share it always it gave
me something meaningful to talk about
when I felt like I had such a
superficial career and I kind of felt at
some point okay I'm not going to be able
to have the career
um
and you know I focused all my attention
on my boys and my activism and just did
things to kind of get by you know to be
financially secure but I kind of felt
especially after
um these home movies were stolen from
Tommy and I and put out there that I had
no chance of having any kind of acting
career I thought
and I wanted to spend more time with my
kids anyway so I thought well
I'm gonna make the best of it and I'll
work here and there but I just felt like
I felt a little bit like I just was
never able to show what I was made of
and that's why when Broadway came around
I was like I need to do this for my soul
I don't know if I can sing or dance or
act on stage and I just wanted to pour
everything into it and work really hard
and do that and to be there on opening
night and closing night and see my kids
there front row and to look at you know
Dylan's little face up at me with those
dimples and just so much pride and I
thought
you know I would we needed that and they
were so proud of me because I've never
really been able to show what I can do
so that was kind of shocking and fun
that it's just so incredible I had no
idea that that would be you know the
part that wrapped up the the documentary
and I was like yeah you did like it was
such a great thing I go outside I go
outside afterwards and people had
flowers I'm like we did it yeah we did
it I'm like we did it we did yeah tears
I know you could do it and it's like it
felt like it was like we and I felt like
wow this is really great I mean the
people that are outside waiting for me
after the show they were just so they
are moved by it because I was editing my
book during the day and doing Broadway
at night so I was fully loaded with all
my emotions of my entire life when I
walked on stage yeah and when I was on
stage I just felt so free and I felt
really great so that's another I'm
really glad I got to do that yeah it's
hard work